- We're told that in a
population of pea plants,
some plants have round seeds
and others have wrinkled seeds.
The gene for seed shape in this population
has two possible alleles.
Remember, alleles are
just versions of the gene.
One allele or one version
is for round seeds,
which we're denoting capital R,
and the other allele is for wrinkled seeds
which we're denoting lowercase R.
And they're telling us
that the round seed allele,
the capital R, is dominant.
For a cross between two pea plants
that are heterozygous
for the seed shape gene,
determine the expected ratio of offspring
with round seeds to offspring
with wrinkled seeds.
All right, like always, pause this video
and see if you can have a go at this
by yourself before we do this together.
All right.
Now let's think about the genotype
for the two pea plants
that are heterozygous.
Heterozygous means they
have two different versions
of the gene, or two different alleles.
So these are going to be two pea plants
that are capital R, lowercase R.
They have one of each.
And to see what happens
in a cross between them,
I will draw a Punnett square.
So just like this, and I will explain
what I am doing in a second here.
So I'll draw it like this.
So what you need to think about
is you have your two parents,
and so each parent is
capital R, lowercase R.
Now that means that let's say parent one
can contribute the
capital R to the offspring
or it could contribute
the lowercase R allele
to the offspring, and the
same thing could happen
for the other parent.
It could contribute the capital R
or it could contribute the lowercase R.
So what are all of the equally likely
possibilities for the offspring?
Well, the offspring might get a capital,
the dominant allele,
the round seed allele,
from both parents, capital R, capital R.
All I'm doing is I'm taking
whatever letter's in the column
and whatever's in the row.
It could get a capital R from this parent
and a lowercase R from that parent.
It could get a lower
case R from this parent
and a capital R from that parent,
or in this situation, it's getting
a lowercase R from either one.
So these are the four
equally likely genotypes.
Now they're not asking us about genotypes.
They're saying determine the
expected ratio of offspring
with round seeds to offspring
with wrinkled seeds.
So what does the genotype
have to look like
in order to have round seeds?
Remember the round seed
allele is dominant.
Well, this would be a
situation where you could be
capital R capital R, but it's dominant.
So you could also be capital R lowercase R
and still have round seeds.
The only way that you're going to have
wrinkled seeds right over here
is if you are homozygous for
the wrinkled seed allele.
So this is the only
wrinkled seed scenario.
So if you look here, you look and see
out of the four equally likely scenarios,
three of them end up with
a phenotype of round seeds
and only one of them
ends up with a phenotype.
Remember, phenotype is
what's being expressed.
Only one of these four
equally likely scenarios
has a phenotype of wrinkled seeds.
So the expected ratio is going to be,
you're gonna expect to see three offspring
with round seeds for every
one with wrinkled seeds
or you would expect a three to one ratio.
Now I have another part of this question
that is asking us, what
about a cross between
a pea plant that is
homozygous for wrinkled seeds
and one that is heterozygous?
Pause the video again and see if you can
have a go at this one.
All right, so the first
thing that I like to do
is just think about, what
are going to be the genotypes
for each of these parents?
So if we're talking about
homozygous for wrinkled seeds,
remember the wrinkled seed
allele, we're denoting
with a lowercase R.
So that's going have a genotype
of lowercase R, lowercase R,
and then they say one
that is heterozygous.
Well, we already saw that before.
That's going to be capital
R and lowercase R. so
let's draw a Punnett square
again, to be able to do this.
So I'll do it like this,
like that, like that
and then make sure I have
two columns and two rows,
and let's put the
homozygous parent up here.
They could either contribute a lowercase R
or they could contribute a lowercase R.
They're gonna contribute one of these two,
and then let's think about
the heterozygous parent.
Well, they can contribute a capital R,
the dominant allele, or they
can contribute a lowercase R.
So let's think about the
equally likely scenarios here,
at least for genotype.
Well, these are all scenarios
in which we get a capital R
from this parent over here,
the heterozygous parent,
I guess I could say.
So let me write capital R, capital R.
And in both of these scenarios,
we're getting the lowercase
R from the homozygous parent.
And both of these situations
are we are getting
the wrinkled seed allele
from both parents.
You're getting the lowercase R
from the heterozygous parent,
and in either scenario,
you're getting a lowercase R
from the homozygous parent.
So let me write that right over here.
So, which of these genotypes would have
a phenotype of round seeds?
Well, round seeds are
going to be scenarios
where you have at least one
of the round seed alleles.
So these are all going to be
round seeds, right over here.
They're going to have a phenotype,
I should say, of round seeds
because remember, the
round allele is dominant.
Even though you have one of each,
the dominant allele is
what you're actually
going to see in the phenotype here.
And then we see these two
are going to be wrinkled, wrinkled.
So what's the ratio of round
to wrinkled going to be?
Well, it's going be one to one.
For every two round, you're
going to have two wrinkled,
or for every one round, you're
going to have one wrinkled.
Two to two is the same thing as one to one
when we're talking about
ratios, and we're done.